PETER HODGSON: Hi,
I'm Peter Hodgson.
I am an interaction designer
working on conversations
with the Google Assistant.
And over the next
few minutes, I'll
be describing the core pillars
to be conscious of when
you're designing
conversational experiences
and some hard learned
design lessons.
But first, let's talk
about conversation itself.
For many people who are new
to designing and building
conversational experiences,
this is the big question
in their mind.
I mean, you can talk.
I can talk.
How hard can it be?
Well, it turns
out that we humans
have had a lot of practice
with conversation.
Recent evidence suggests that
humans have been conversing
for up to half a million years.
Researchers have discovered
that the common ancestor
of Neanderthals and
Homo sapiens had
the hyoid bone in their throat,
which controls the tongue.
And conversation is inherently
social and contextual.
Every one of us here has
been practicing speaking
since before we could walk.
So it's literally
instinctive to us,
which makes it extremely complex
and subtle and hard to codify.
As a colleague of
ours likes to say,
we don't have to think about
conversation in the same way
that fish don't have to
think about the water.
The key point for us
all is that people
aren't going to change how
they converse anytime soon.
So we need to design
conversational interfaces
to match people's expectations.
We're teaching computers to
speak human, not the other way
around.
The good news is
that people have
been studying and researching
language for a long time.
And we can leverage
that knowledge
when designing
conversational interfaces.
And when you're starting
to design conversations
there are three ideas
or pillars that I think
you should pin on the wall.
The first pillar is the
cooperative principle
identified by the philosopher
of language Paul Grice.
It describes the rules
and assumptions we all
abide by in our conversations.
And we do so entirely
subconsciously.
His maxims of quality,
quantity, relevance, and manner
can be used as
reliable guidelines
when you're creating
conversations.
For example, the
maxim of quantity
says that we expect participants
in a conversation to
and I quote, "not make
their contributions
more or less informative
than is required
to advance the conversation."
And I'll bet you can
all recall conversations
you've had with people who
are not abiding by this maxim.
That's the person
who talks too much
or the person who
doesn't say enough.
So I encourage you all to
study the cooperative principle
in detail.
If the cooperative
principle deals
with the content or the
fuel of a conversation,
then turn taking is the
engine and the gearbox.
And it is the second
pillar to bear in mind.
Turn taking is the
mechanism by which
we resolve ambiguity and
repair conversations in order
to progress to a
final resolution.
Linguists will refer to
people handing the turn
or taking the turn
in a conversation.
And in the real world we
use linguistic prompts--
questions or just
body language--
to signify when the
turn should be taken.
For the moment,
Virtual Assistant
understand none of these
subtle social cues.
So turn taking for
conversational assistance
has to be more explicit.
And we have to manage this when
writing dialogue so it doesn't
become unnatural or robotic.
The third pillar is to
design conversations that
work for the user's context.
Talking to machines is
still in its infancy.
And people still find
it socially awkward.
So you should actively focus
on the user's physical context
and the kinds of
conversations they're
open to in that context.
And look to design for
simple, intuitive, high value
conversations while people are
in socially safe environments
and where voice interactions
have less friction than touch.
So the three pillars are the
cooperative principle, turn
taking, and the user context.
And here are my five
top lessons learned.
First, persona-- designing
your system's persona
is not a nice to have.
It's a must have.
There's another
video in this series.
And it's a detailed
talk about this topic,
which I encourage you to watch.
But it's worth
highlighting here.
A persona is a style
template for your brand.
You should design it
and use it to provide
a common understanding and
a reference for consistency
during every step of your
conversational design
development.
As another colleague puts
it, if you don't clearly
define your brand personas,
then your users will.
Second-- and another must do--
start with the sample dialog--
whatever the platform,
you'll be deploying on.
Create end-to-end sample dialogs
for the most likely cases.
Writing the dialog
will help you discover
more cases and the
conversational logic
you'll need to build.
Don't just write the dialog.
Speak it out loud
with someone else.
It'll change what
you've written.
And present dialog
to stakeholders
in the audio channel,
not as written text.
You can record it
using a TTS engine
and listen to the playback.
After you've nailed the most
likely cases in the sample
dialogs, then design
all the repair cases.
Designing for
conversational repair
is the topic of another video.
But bear these things in mind.
We need to make
conversations work
well when it goes off track.
These can be points of
great user frustration.
And so if handled well,
they're great opportunities
to rebuild user
trust and confidence.
Your Assistants
should be forgiving.
Remember, people
are instinctively
trying to be cooperative.
But we're human.
And we make mistakes.
So we need to be highly focused
on helping them get back
on track as naturally
as possible.
And here's a top tip.
A key approach for
identifying repair cases
is to prototype the
conversation as early
as you can in the process.
Write and perform the
conversations with real users.
And use "Wizard
of Oz" techniques
with audio recordings to test
your conversational structure
and dialog.
Next we're building
a system for users
to access their
Assistant anywhere.
So you must consider your
conversational experiences
across modalities and surfaces.
In some cases, the
conversational logic
might have to change
depending on the surface.
For example, presenting
choices to users on an eyes
free device, such
as a Google Home
requires different
dialog strategies
than when the user can pick from
a list of choices on a screen.
And designing for multi-modal
conversations with the screen
is hard.
The important thing
to remember is
that in multi-modal
conversations
the screen is only one output
of the conversational state.
There's both audio and visual
channels to be choreographed.
So think hard about
the best channels
for information transfer.
What's best on screen?
What's best in audio?
Where's the right balance
for your conversation?
In a multi-modal
experience screens
are really great for presenting
large amounts of information.
They're great for
displaying touch avoidances
to repair or to progress a
conversation more quickly
than with another spoken turn.
And the screens are useful
for orienting the user and way
finding in a multi-step task.
Finally, with the
Assistant you're
designing for use over time.
The second conversation
with the user
will always be different
from the first.
And the third may be
different from the second.
We expect a
conversational Assistant
to understand and remember us.
So the conversations
should reflect that memory.
Just keeping track of previous
conversations and a user's
context and adjusting
the conversation
based on these
cues will increase
the perception of an
intelligent agent significantly.
So design your persona.
Always start with
the sample dialogs.
Repair with context sensitivity.
Design cross platform from
eyes free to multimodal.
And design for frequency.
And never forget the
cooperative principle.
Good luck with your
conversation design.
And thanks for listening.